le lave-vaisselle et par là oui mais
l'arrivée d'eau et dans le placard de la
chambre non n'entrez pas non pourquoi
c'est ok
je peux le faire moi merci on sait qu'à
des gens très copieux
donc le lave vaisselle
il est un drôle de bruit une espèce de
claquements chaque fois qu'il se vide
[Musique]
ces vieux tuyaux c'est un bruit de bain
nous y sommes il n'ya pas d'animal ici
en effet vous avez dit que vous ne
cherchiez pas et on en cherche pas donc
il ne peut pas vous hâter reçues
[Musique]
il est trop trop dommageable
il est reçu et aux milices qu'il est
tout rouge simple est qu'il soit rouge
d'où ça vient fort colère je ne sais pas
je crois qu'il a perdu sa famille il est
désorienté pauvre petit moi je serai ta
famille non tu seras pas t'en prions
plus casey tu vois bien qu'il est tout
petit il embêtera personnes lésées
bridwell il va faire quelle taille b e
je ne sais pas ce dépôt de quoi de
l'amour que tu lui donneras
[Musique]
non ce coupé en plus quasi peut rester
juste une wii
seulement une nuit
[Musique]
il va beaucoup grandir ça dépend de
l'amour que tu es de méthode
clifford comment ça a pu arriver
[Musique]
c'est un grand chien ou jeu trop mignon
vous n'êtes plus active que les
courriers prendre sa température ou sa
température qu'il est à nous
tu parles tu as pas caché
comment ça se fait qu'il ait pas encore
éclaté
à mailhac a demandé
on ne voit que ça sur internet un chien
de 3 m d'euros en plein manhattan sont
pas être frais ils devront 25000 dollars
de récompense pour la capture du grand
chien rouge les gens ils n'aiment pas ce
qui est différent
il n'existe aucun chien d'une part
qu'ils soient comme toi qu'est ce qu'il
fait je crois qu'ils essaient de se
faire péter
[Musique]
pendant vos prix quoi a prôné le savez
dieu vient on vient
t'es sérieux
imagine que tu entends quelqu'un qui est
tellement plein d'amour
qui constituent sont capables de tout ça
sur m'a sauvé la vie
petit porte du quartier mais tu sais
conduire est pas compliqué
je vais être puni pour la ville à tous
les deux à mon avis
il mange comme un argument c'est un
animal je parlais de l'us haut
[Musique]